e já é
e aí
e eu tenho me perguntado constantemente
e qual é a minha parte para fazer do
brasil um país melhor para todos isso
tem-me inquietado bastante
oi e o seu escutei respostas muito
diferentes para essa pergunta
e eu ajudo uma creche eu cumpro as leis
eu não pago propina eu faço a doação
para uma igreja e o trabalho muito mas
quando nós olhamos para o nosso país
esse brasil real que tem um contexto bem
mais complexo como podemos de fato fazer
a diferença isso me faz lembrar de
quando eu participei do encontro de
jovens eu tenho uns 20 anos e um
coordenador do grupo solicitou que cada
jovem falasse dos seus problemas eu
fiquei assustada eu não me sentia com
problemas pelo menos naquela época
e-mail aquela situação sem saber o que
fazer me perguntei se para estar ali eu
tinha que ter problemas
e esse fato ele sempre me faz refletir
que para a gente fazer a diferença nós
não precisamos passar por problemas ou
mesmo achar que só grandes ações ou
grandes embates podem mudar uma
realidade até porque em um país como o
nosso com tantos desafios o que não
falta é oportunidade para mudança
no conto esses fatos para apresentar a
vocês uma experiência impactante e
transformadora que está acontecendo numa
região de pernambuco nessa região a
renda média da população é baixa e o
índice de analfabetismo e quase três
vezes maior do que o índice do brasil
mas foi nessa região no sertão do
araripe que eu tive uma resposta bem
diferente e especial para pergunta que
me que é tava
e lá as pessoas elas não inventam
desculpas para as suas dificuldades elas
buscam as alternativas e põe energia
para implantá-las eu estava trabalhando
em um projeto que visava criar condições
da agricultura familiar aumentar suas
vendas para o governo a intenção era que
seus produtos fossem vendidos para a
merenda das escolas públicas dos
municípios de araripina santa filomena e
granito era uma grande oportunidade para
os produtores rurais aumentar as suas
vendas
o inicialmente achamos que só era
capacitar as equipes de governo para
fazer processo de mais simples de
compras e os produtores rurais para
entregar seus produtos nos critérios lá
estabelecidos pelo governo só que isso
não deu certo
as pessoas elas precisavam se envolver
faltava algo que fizesse a ligação entre
todos os envolvidos elas precisavam se
reconhecer como agente de mudança
precisava ter um significado maior um
elo de fato e elas precisavam se
apropriar da força do cola da
colaboração do coletivo e foram os
produtores rurais os primeiros que
começaram a fazer a mudança e juntar as
pontas dance difícil processo de
integração eles foram capacitados para
saber vender para o governo e para
produzir também alimentos seguros e de
qualidade
é só que eles não iam produzir para
qualquer um os seus produtos e os e
consumidos pelos seus filhos pelos seus
netos pelos seus sobrinhos pelos seus
vizinhos isso foi que deu um significado
singular para os produtores rurais e as
equipes do governo o que fazer para que
ela se sentisse biliza sem para fazer
processos mais acessíveis de compras e
passa entendimento e que pudessem de
fato fazer com que os produtores rurais
pudessem participar
e mais uma vez foi empoderamento que deu
certo eles foram não só os responsáveis
ufa já atendeu a legislação que obrigava
eles a comprar da agricultura familiar
mas principalmente por aumentar a renda
das pessoas do seu município e por
proporcionar uma alimentação variada e
nutritiva para as crianças mas ainda
temos um grande desafio pela frente
mudar os cardápios das escolas boa parte
desses cardápios já estava elaborado com
produtos aqui não eram da região e
alguns industrializados com receitas
prontas mais fáceis de serem entregues e
de serem manipuladas
e o que fazer para envolver as
nutricionistas e merendeiras a também
entrarem nesse processo de mudança e de
melhoria de vida para as pessoas
trouxemos receitas novas realizamos
curso de culinária e concursos de
receita tudo isso envolvendo o poder de
transformação de cada um
o e ao fazerem novas receitas elas
desenvolveram também há outras
habilidades e os talentos dela foram
destacadas e quem não gosta ser
valorizado e de estar sempre aprendendo
e ela já aderiram mudar e seus cardápios
e o famoso bode do sertão passou a ser
alimento essencial para as crianças da
região e foi body para todo gosto bode
assado bode guisado body com legumes bom
de qualquer jeito tinha lá o que não
faltou foi receita toda já estavam ali
reunidos envolvidos merendeiras
nutricionistas produtores rurais
instituições equipes do governo movidos
por uma alimentação mais saudável para
as crianças que envolvesse os produtos
locais valorizando a região e as pessoas
que produziam lá e todos sabiam que
aumentar a renda dos produtores
significava melhor qualidade de vida
para as famílias
a e os resultados foram muito bons por
que não dizer excelentes mas não dá para
falar de resultados sem falar de seu
edinho seu edinho é produtor rural lá de
riacho fundo 1 distrito que fica a 40 km
de araripina e que foi um dos
beneficiados pelo projeto
e ele tem uma capacidade incrível de
juntar as pessoas de colaborar de
liderar e fazer com que elas acreditem
na sua força de mudar para melhor
e ele é casado tem dois filhos e muitos
netos e já foi técnico de futebol
inclusive eu acho que foi no futebol que
ele desenvolver essa capacidade de
trabalhar com as pessoas de fazer com
que todos se unam para um objetivo maior
e compartilhado
e pense num homem animado
é aquela pessoa que sempre está disposta
a colaborar e ajudar que tem um orgulho
do seu trabalho da sua região e faz tudo
com os outros
o seu edinho já traz a tua com essa
associação há muitos anos esperança é
que move seu edinho aquela esperança
romântica que muitas vezes a gente fala
mas ele acredita e trabalha para mudar
sua realidade e para alcançar os seus
objetivos por isso eu convidei seu
edinho para estar aqui conosco hoje
e você vai vir cá
e aí
o seu edinho muito obrigada muito
obrigada pela prendizado da colaboração
e por nos encher de tanta esperança
e aí
o que vocês querem saber os resultados
para a comunidade riacho fundo antes de
participar dos projetos nesse projeto a
comunidade produzirá praticamente para
subsistência eles não tinham renda hoje
eles têm uma renda de 1.400 reais ou
produtor e seu edinho me falou há duas
semanas que essa esse valor vai dobrar
até o final do ano
é só para vocês terem uma ideia a
comunidade do riacho fundo passou a
vender 300 mil reais só para merenda
escolar do município de araripina por
ano e o município de araripina que
comprava muito pouco da agricultura
familiar comprou em dois anos e meio 1
milhão 437.000 reais
e isso não é pouco isso é muito de um
projeto desse no trabalho para uma
comunidade é dessa esse projeto já está
sendo implantado em mais duas regiões do
estado de pernambuco e já foi
apresentado para nos estados do piauí e
do amapá
o que vocês acham e pararam por aí não a
comunidade achou que podia muito mais
hoje eu estou trabalhando juntamente com
a equipe é excelente e com parceiros em
um novo projeto
e a exportação do mel de pernambuco para
o mundo
é isso mesmo porque não pensar grande
quando nós pensamos juntos isso faz
muita diferença essa experiência da
agricultura família a vender para o
governo criou um círculo virtuoso de
otimismo e força de integração de muita
gente capaz de transformar uma ideia de
mais de 10 anos de exportação do mel em
ações concretas e eu tenho convicção em
2019 nós estaremos celebrando mas essa
conquista do coletivo do plural de
muitas pessoas e de instituições também
bom e é por isso que aquela pergunta que
eu falei lá atrás teve que ser mudada
não adianta querer fazer só a nossa
parte temos que fazer a nossa parte
integrada com a dos outros envolver
outras pessoas e atuar de forma
colaborativa e aí eu pergunto o que você
está fazendo juntamente com outras
pessoas para fazer do brasil um país
melhor para nós vivermos obrigada
[Aplausos]